Hotel Transylvania 3 summer vacation is
once again directed by genndy
tartakovsky one of my favorite animation
directors and he's directed the previous
two and this time for the first time in
the series he's actually taken part in a
screenwriting credit and this film
follows a very lonely Dracula who's
beginning to feel like he would like a
partner mavis his daughter feels bad for
him and so she invites him on this
surprise cruise with all of her monster
family so we leave Hotel Transylvania
and go out onto the water and we
experienced their adventure as they meet
some people who maybe want to do them in
for good this is a strange series for me
because I've enjoyed both of the
previous entries while critics have been
kind of lukewarm on them this is a
series that people seem to enjoy a lot
more than critics and I'm not exactly
sure why genndy tartakovsky is someone
who has made some of my favorite
animations he just completed season 5 of
Samurai Jack which I thought was
masterful he's a brilliant animation
director I loved his timing I loved his
editing the Clone Wars micro series was
fantastic Dexter's Laboratory I've
always appreciated his work and with the
Hotel Transylvania films I feel like
they find a really good medium with
entertaining children and adults while
also having a lot of smart humor thrown
in and while summer vacation isn't as
good as the first film I found it about
on par with the second in regards to its
entertainment value it's filled with
visual inventiveness and a lot of
creative character designs
it has good jokes it has some actual
funny sequences and tons of adult humor
just like the previous two there's a lot
of jokes that your kids are not going to
understand there's a tentacle joke I
think for God's sakes this film has even
more adult humor than the last which I
really appreciated because if you're
gonna take your kids to a film like this
you might as well have a few things that
you can just kind of keep in their
recesses of your brain and then you know
one day maybe a little Johnny he'll get
that but for now that's just for you
this film and the previous two before it
feel different than your average
animation nowadays like say from Pixar
Incredibles to feels like a film it
feels like an experience the Hotel
Transylvania movies feel like cartoons
and I mean that as a positive and this
very well could be because of
Tartakovsky
background with Cartoon Network these
movies feel like entertainment that
doesn't make you feel like an idiot you
can enjoy the characters you can have
fun laughing at their situations but in
particular it's the character design and
the visual creativeness with every
single monster no two are the same
the whole film has a lot of great sight
gags as a result because it's able to
use these monsters and their different
abilities to get a lot of good jokes an
early sequence on a gremlin airline
where it's an airplane run by a bunch of
gremlins that don't care about you
they'll take your luggage throw it out
the window
it's like the most uncomfortable plane
ever but it's cheap and it's for
monsters only there's a lot of great
moments like that that do have a bit of
a hidden message in there because just
like the other two the underlying moral
of the film is that humans and monsters
can coexist you're allowed to look at
someone else who might be different than
you and appreciate them for who they are
despite those differences on surface
level and that's something that kids are
gonna appreciate and take away from and
hopefully apply to their own life summer
vacation isn't gonna go down as an
animation classic nor world of first two
but this series is a fun enough cartoon
that adults can find a lot of enjoyment
in as well as kids because there's tons
of jokes that only adults are going to
appreciate as I said there's two
characters the two werewolves who have
their children constantly on them
clawing at their skin they never get any
free time and when they find a daycare
on the ship a werewolf is like you'll
take our kids by choice and a lot of
parents in the audience laughed at that
and the kids were just kind of like
silent but that's a joke entirely for
the parents and there's tons of stuff
like that in this movie as far as
storytelling beats it's going to be very
obvious from the beginning if you've
ever seen any movie ever you pretty much
can understand where all the Domino
pieces are going to topple and where
characters will make choices and things
that are going to happen there's no
surprises really it is different than
the other two because it takes place on
a cruise ship and so you have a new
environment with new things that you can
do and so it does feel sort of like its
own thing compared to the others it's
not quite as funny it's not quite as
fresh as the first one but it is more
fast paced I would say than the second
because it does kind of feel like a
series of jokes and that could also be a
negative because
sometimes you get a lot of jokes and you
laugh a lot and it's chuckle worthy but
where's the story going and you
understand that its core it's really
just about Dracula being lonely and his
family wanting to help him but there
isn't that much under the surface and
that's fine I don't think that every
animated film has to be mind-blowing
lead deep some are just meant to teach
kids a lesson while also entertaining
them and while critics will likely jump
on the fact that the film has a big
finale involving dancing and music this
movie goes for it it really puts
everything out there and just kind of
blows up with his crazy sequence that in
the end kind of won me over at first I
was like are they really doing this all
right they are I guess they're going for
it and I heard a lot of children around
me laughing and having a good time and
that's the divide I think right there
between critics who go to this film and
they want to express whether or not they
were entertained by it but in the long
run it really is made for families and I
feel like families will enjoy this movie
and if you like the first two you'll
probably find enjoyment in it as well
just like my wife and I did today I'm to
give Hotel Transylvania 3 of B also side
point there is something that animations
do commonly when someone gets beat the
hell up like their wounds disappear
seconds later because it's a cartoon
there's a scene in this where Dracula
gets like a hundred arrows in his body
and acts and his head snakes are biting
his arms and I kept waiting for them to
disappear but they remain on him for the
entirety of the rest of the scene and it
got so hilarious they weren't going away
and I was like Tartakovsky is playing
with animation tropes right now and I
don't feel like a lot of people are
going to appreciate that that's
something that he does so differently
than your average animation director
that you you just forget about in two
seconds and I appreciate that about him
as a filmmaker I want to see more from
him I hope to see more films from him if
you guys haven't seen Samurai Jack it's
on Blu right now please check it out
it's one of the best cartoons ever made
guys thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]